[Musique]
thierry coville bonjour merci d'être
avec nous ce matin en direct sur rt
france les autorités iraniennes prête
refuge aux dirigeants al quaida et leur
apportent leur soutien c'est donc ce
qu'a affirmé hier le secrétaire d'état
michael popeo alors sur quoi se basent
style pour dire pour dire ça alors on
sait que si vous voulez après la défaite
des talibans et d'al qaïda
donc en 2002 en afghanistan sans doute
pour échapper aux forces américaines des
dirigeants d'al qaïda aurait pu trouver
refuge en iran
pourquoi ils sont en iran je pense que
c'est vraiment de c'est plutôt tactique
c'est à dire l'iran déjà penser mieux
les contrôler et puis voilà
éventuellement le fait de détenir des
dirigeants d'al qaïda comme une monnaie
des changes dans d'éventuelles futures
négociations par exemple avec les états
unis mais en déduire qu'il ya une
alliance stratégique entre l'iran et al
qaïda s'étaient même c'est effectivement
dire une contre-vérité parce
qu'effectivement les services américains
eux mêmes en doute tout le monde en
doute
enfin je veux dire demander à quelle
n'importe quel service secret sérieux ou
n'importe quel expert sérieux de dire
qu'il ya une alliance entre autres les
rangs al qaeda c'est c'est complètement
faux c'est sur le plan idéologique il
faut quand même rappeler que pour des
groupes extrémistes sunnites comme al
qaïda ou l'état islamique les chiffres
sont des hérétiques et sur le plan
militaire à 3,4 appelait monsieur pompéo
que si l'iran est présent syrie ou en
irak c'est pour se battre justement
contre les forces d'al qaïda bon qui
s'appelle en syrie maintenant il
s'appelle aldo sera besoins en outre
nous maintenant mais c'est quand même
extraordinaire d'accuser l'iran d'être
alliés avec des groupes contre lesquels
il perd des hommes hilton se bat karé
ment l'iran est la seule armée à de la
région qui se bat contre contre ces
forces extrémistes sunnites dans la
région alors justement comment
comprendre aujourd'hui cette déclaration
de mike on pe c'est la suite logique de
la politique de pression maximum contre
l'iran
on va dire c'est quand même les derniers
feux de cette politique il faut rappeler
complètement échoué
les ait coupés ou lui-même a fixé deux
objectifs 12 terme de sujets de
négociation ce que l'iran devait
accepter pour que les états unis
arrêtent leur politique de pression
maximum qui contient surtout des
sanctions économiques ont dévasté
l'économie iranienne
les vendre a cédé sur aucun point donc
je pense qu'ils sont plutôt dans une
tactique de gêner de gêner la future
administration américaine comme ils
savent que al qaeda est un sujet très
sensible aux états unis donc associé
quelque part l'iran et avec qaïda dans
l'idée des dirigeants actuels américain
s'est gêné des futures négociations
entre l'administration byden et les et
l'iran
quel est justement le point de vue de
joe biden sur l'iran sur la position
durant leurs premiers points
je crois qu'il est déjà sur cette
antenne c'est joe biden est très clair
il veut revenir dans l'accord sur les
routes 2015 donc ça c'est très important
dont l'iran et les états unis
quoiqu'en pensent l'administration trump
vont commencer à se reparler deuxième
fois aussi qui est également très
important dans les choix qu'il a fait de
son équipe qui verra ce que les
politiques étrangères il ya des gens qui
connaissent l'iran contrairement
justement à l'équipe de donald trump
donc ils savent tous ce que raconte
actuellement monsieur pompéo ils savent
que c'est complètement fou donc je pense
que les ça va être compliqué mais joe
maiden veut rediscuter récurrents déjà
dans un premier temps il veut revenir
dans l'accord sud est clair de 2015
alors ce n'est pas la première fois que
l'administration tram fait le lien entre
l'iran et al qaïda dans une série de
tweets il ya plus d'un an c'était cette
fois mike pence ce qui avait justifié
l'assassinât de souleymane sy en lui
attribuant une part de responsabilité
dans les attentats du 11-septembre
garder la force al qods a aidé au voyage
clandestin en afghanistan de dix des
douze terroristes qui ont perpétré les
attentats terroristes du 11 septembre
aux états unis alors selon un rapport
officiel de la commission sur le 11
septembre 2001 ou qu'une prendre une
clean preuve là encore n'est avancée
c'est bien cela
associer les rangs 11 septembre 2001
c'est tellement stupide incohérent il
réalise c'est faux je veux dire c'est
complètement faux pas paul pour la
petite histoire je crois que la
population iranienne a été la seule dans
la région a exprimé sa compassion pour
les victimes du 11 septembre 2001 tous
les dirigeants iraniens
il ya un très très bon documentaire de
la bbc qui peut voir sujet de tous les
dirigeants iraniens étaient surpris vous
devrez absolument pas au courant de
cette attaque du 11-septembre et et on
peut également rappeler que les talibans
qui ont hébergé caucus qui hébergeait
qui ont aidé al qaïda était dédiée à
l'époque un des ennemis mortels de
l'iran qui avait les talibans avaient
par exemple assassiner des diplomates
iraniens à mazar i sharif quand il avait
envahi l'afghanistan donc associer les
rucks étant passés aussi à montre aussi
à quel point les dirigeants américains
jouent sur l'ignorance des faits de la
population américaine pour oser propager
ce type de formation le new york times
avait également rapporté en novembre qu
abou mohamed al masri numéro deux d'al
qaïda avaient été tués par des agents
israéliens en iran est ce qu'on en sait
plus aujourd'hui sous les mois je suis
expert je suis pas journaliste mais
policiers mais je vous rappelle ce qu'on
sait par contre et ça c'est vrai on sait
que l'iran a sans doute héberge sans
doute des dirigeants le d'al-qaïda donc
dont il faisait partie avec l'idée
c'était vraiment déjà de mieux les
contrôler parce que quand je voulais
rappeler à des groupes comme al qaida je
parlais de renault sera en syrie reste
fondamentalement opposée à la république
islamique d'iran et au chic en général
et puis également de les utiliser comme
future monnaie des changes dans
d'éventuelles négociations et qu'ils
étaient leaders ça c'est vrai ça c'est
un fait on sait que sans doute la
république islamique d'iran détient un
certain nombre de dirigeants d'al-qaïda
belhade je répète en déduire qu'une
alliance le quelconque militaire ce que
vous voulez entre l'iran et qaïda c'est
fou
merci beaucoup tirent ils pour thierry
conil pour votre éclairage ce matin je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheur à
l'iris spécialiste de l'iran